[Music]
okay
so picture this you're in a match
spectating someone
watching a vaude or scrutinizing a kill
cam
and out of nowhere you see a meandering
crosshair flicks seamlessly onto some
dude's chest
what would you be thinking i mean i know
what you'd be thinking
this kid is cheating
he knows oh we got him we get we got
that son of a [ __ ]
no that's triggerbot that's triggerboss
oh
there it is we got him now what if i
told you that the cheater in question
wasn't using aimlock what if i told you
that they were totally above
board had no third-party software
installed and were simply being offered
a little bit of
in-client assistance all because they're
using
a controller controllers easy man
you barely you don't even have to aim my
guy's literally looking left and right
as cypher's moving left and right and
and it just it
it's following him now more than ever
with cross play on the rise and
battle royales becoming some of the
biggest titles in gaming
the controversial controller-centric
mechanic known as aim assist
is facing tons of scrutiny some
feel very strongly that it has no place
in a competitive shooter so if a mouse
and keyboard
isn't fair against a controller or vice
versa
because they both have their pros and
cons they shouldn't exist in the same
world
others however genuinely don't see what
the big deal is
the majority of these players that make
any success are on keyboard and mouse so
what does it matter
just let the controller players exist so
let's
air this [ __ ] out once and for all
because the question
isn't as simple as is aim assist
cheating
it's even if it is can we
ever actually get rid of it
[Applause]
alright fellow cracked fiends
ah crap crackheads nope
uh man there's just no way to
endearingly refer to our fans that does
not carry some
real negative energy uh well
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications
that's it that's all i wanted to say
okay so before we
flick straight on to the spicy
controversial stuff
we should take a second to answer the
very reasonable question that i'm sure
all of the league players out there have
which is what in the flying [ __ ]
is aim assist it's quite simple actually
aim assist is a
decades-old mechanic that makes it so
that once your crosshair has come within
a certain proximity of an enemy target
it automatically tracks said target
huh oh don't worry i'm going to correct
him in a minute
now before y'all start cracking quips
about aim hacks and whatnot
we should also take a second to answer
yet another
very reasonable question which is
how did aim assist come to exist in the
first place and
look i know what you're thinking like
all of gaming's infernal
annoyances aim assist must have been
pioneered on the
cesspool that is console right
well as it turns out
yes i mean kind of you see technically
you can find
early traces of aim assist in the
original doom
which for all you zoomers out there is
basically the rock on which the church
of first person shooters was built
since you could only aim sideways your
reticle would
actually snap to enemies below ledges
[Music]
but it wasn't until the advent of the
nintendo 64
and the release of such foundational
titles as goldeneye
duke nukem zero hour and perfect dark
that aim assist was thrust into the
hands of every
wide-eyed cross-legged basement dwelling
runt in the known universe
and yes it was beyond broken but that
was okay
because aside from some casual split
screen multiplayer
it was always being used against npcs
take that see why can't cod be that easy
at aiming
the issue of course is that eventually
humans entered the mix like in halo now
as it turns out the way that aim assist
functions in master chief's floaty
funhouse of stick-steered destruction
is actually kind of complicated and
admittedly
i have no idea how it works mostly
because i don't care it just so happens
that
colton is a seasoned former
halo player competitor person i don't
know
anyway i'm gonna hop on twitter real
quick while he explains to you how this
mechanic that we in counter-strike refer
to as
cheating became referred to in console
communities
as competing someone needs to teach that
kid some respect
aim assist isn't just the game
automatically moving your reticle onto
the enemy's head
there's a lot more subtlety here who
better to break it all down than the
resident halo nerd
in halo ce and across most controller
fps games there are two systems at work
bullet magnetism and aim assist bullet
magnetism is the game
shifting the projectile or hit scan
impact point from the center of your
crosshair
closer to an enemy while aim assist is
the slowing of the crosshair movement
as it passes over an enemy player across
different fps games there's a lot of
nuance in how these two systems are
implemented
especially from the pioneers over at
bungie aim assist and bullet magnetism
are adjusted on each weapon individually
from the range that it kicks in to
whether it happens at all
like the sniper rifle which has no aim
assist when descoped but has an
extremely long aim assist range when
scoped
these systems and the fact that at the
end of the day you still have to
consistently get your reticle to the
enemy player
something dimitri struggles with daily
in cs are a part of the beautifully high
skill ceiling in halo ce
even among the best players in the world
there was an obvious skill gap when it
came to aiming prowess
so just because the game is helping you
doesn't mean your own hand eye and game
sense wasn't a huge factor
controller phenoms like clockwork and
the ogre twins to snipe down and i got
your pistola have created some of the
hypest moments that the burgeoning n.a
esports scene has ever seen
so maybe check yourself a bit before you
go devaluing console pro's undeniable
talent
there's a reason these guys are winning
majors and you're talking about it in
front of a camera
dimitri is he done
he is oh thank god okay now it goes
without saying that
back in the day when consoles were on
the come up
and you know actually cool the
introduction of
aim assist made a ton of sense anyone
who grew up in the 90s can attest to
this
have you ever tried aiming with an n64
controller
it feels like you're playing video games
with a [ __ ] bop-it
even as dual analog sticks became the
norm
it remained very obvious that
maintaining precise
pinpoint accuracy with a controller just
wasn't ideal
aiming solely using one's thumbs could
be clunky and chaotic
so an in-client assist was both an
elegant and intuitive solution
oh man
okay look you all knew this was coming
so
let's just get it out of the way is the
mouse
a definitively better input device when
it comes to
any video game that involves raw
unassisted aiming
yes it is cry all you want
it's a fact you don't even have to take
my word for it
just consult a study or wink wink
ask our resident grip guru garrick
foreman who you may remember from our
mouse grip episode and is currently
completing his phd in ergonomics and
neuromechanics at brock university when
you're using a mouse
you have three major joints so your
shoulder elbow and wrist
that can all make adjustments to perfect
your aim
just all together in the form you have
so many muscles and joints to be able to
get precise aim give a ton of muscles
that are doing
very specific fine functions very fine
movements
and they can kind of play off each other
and cycle off if they start to get tired
whereas you don't have that in the hand
especially in the thumb you don't have
the thumb basically is like the opposite
to what i said
it basically has one muscle that
performs each movement so
if you're playing for hours just using
your thumb and that muscle starts to get
tired you're going to be played worse
according to garrick there's just this
plainly scientific sense
in which aiming solely using one's
thumbs will just
never be as easy or efficient as using
the sort of
combo that is the shoulder elbow wrist
trifecta
uh but in that sense yes i i think it's
much easier to
aim with mouse uh mouse keyboard than it
is to with a controller just because of
how much
how much more functional tissue you have
using the mouse you have like just so
much muscle mass that can
be adding to that because you have three
joints too
it also allows you to correct for
errors at any one of those joints so if
you are making any kind of
error at your shoulder joint you can
correct with it at your elbow a little
bit you can definitely correct for it at
your wrist
so that that's really the benefit of
using the wrist and why it's such an
important part of the body is you
it's the end effector of anything you're
doing so the wrist
is basically correct for any kind of
errors that you that are introduced to
the function
higher up in the limb in a sense then
you can think of aim assist as
compensating for the absence of the
wrist as
recreating those sort of quick snappy
correctives that the thumb by its very
nature
struggles to produce so if an enemy is
right there when i flick with my arm
i obviously want to be as close as i can
to that
but that's where the arm and wrist
hybrid comes from right is you have a
range of control
and so even if he's here and i flick to
there with my arm
see how fast my correction was so he's
here i flick my arm
i'm still on the spot i want to aim
cause that's my range of control
because of this aim assist is was
and always will be an indispensable
learning tool for console adoring
casuals
and to be clear i don't mean casuals in
the derogatory sense
i mean actual controller-wielding
children who know nothing
about esports like colton
flahm says the dude's name once and he
thinks he's something
i think that aim assist is really really
great for the average player and i think
that's probably why it was introduced
because if you come in
from like especially still trying to get
into games if you come into a game
and you suck at aiming you are not going
to want to play that game anymore
so i think that a lot of the reason like
the aim assist is
so important is because it creates such
a great playing experience for so many
people
and definitely when you're looking at
the upper echelons of
pro play that's where you got to start
to think is it necessary and i think
that
if you're if you really want to get into
it i would say probably take it off
you know if you are as good if you're
the best the best you probably don't
need it
and if you are best the best let's see
how good you are without it
that said eventually aim assist
also became a bit of a crutch
even for competitors people told me to
take off aim assist and i know
so many people have done this no
amethyst stuff but uh
i think i haven't i haven't done it per
se
i'm about to throw up because that was
awful
this is [ __ ] dude the thing is for a
long time the ubiquitousness of aim
assist from an
esports perspective wasn't that big of a
deal
since console and pc esports were kept
separate
and everyone in the former was using a
controller there were no unfair
advantages per se
since everyone had access to said assist
and then in the late 2010s crossplay
came along
before long you had heavily populated
battle royale extravaganzas
such as fortnite warzone and apex
legends
in which keems and controllers were
facing off against one another
in not only casual settings but
competitive ones
and it was in that ladder context kids
where things
started to get a little bit heated i've
watched you try to l2 spam and it
doesn't work and then you start
l spamming and just literally aiming and
you're zooming in on
i don't know yo the first game you're
telling me that the new one is
broken now you're telling me that you're
watching me and it doesn't work you
gotta
pick one homie you can't just say it
works
and it doesn't work my aim i'm shot
people
all day boy i've been just destroying
people well too
you see on the one hand you can't take
away console players aim assist
since well for starters it's a part of
their game
they learned to play with it what's more
in the vast majority of circumstances
they
need it in order to stand a chance
against mouse aimers
the issue is that as soon as a pc
player dies to what is essentially a
glorified aimbot
dude controller man like it's just
hacking bro like
it's actually just hacking
sickboy
when you're up against the pressure of
somebody who can consistently five shot
that [ __ ] hard aiming doesn't always
come
that's super great i'm done with it
it's done zooed this game sucks you
dwinner
i'm super [ __ ] over it the question
of course is
in a competitive context where cross
play is a thing
is using aim assist cheating
yes i mean i'll put it this way it's a
shitload
closer to cheating than it is to not
cheating
the whole point of competition is like
fair play
you know competitive integrity right so
if a mouse and keyboard
isn't fair against a controller or vice
versa because they both have their pros
and cons
they shouldn't exist in the same world
it's really that simple
the fact that people are arguing against
any of that
is crazy to me now is it true that there
are
certain controller players who are so
nutty that they actually don't
need aim assist yes my boy
priest for instance stepped onto the
stage of the raleigh major back in
august of 2019
played in the creator cup and squared up
against shroud on land
with the controller and no he wasn't
using aim assist
this is for all the console players at
home right now you can tell all your pc
friends to shut their mouth
could possibly win out this gunfight
it's gonna be a quick rotation he had
the skeleton key
pressuring through doesn't have time and
no
so close he had the angle and everything
the issue is that such phenoms are
so few and far between that you could
never in good conscience
balance an entire esport around them in
call of duty for instance
aim assist is pretty much intrinsically
linked to the mechanics of the franchise
even the game's most cracked killers
rely on it to land
nutty shots in the in the sky uh
straight ahead i'm about to beam him
real quick he's right here
live mark mark the target
he's broken he's gone forever so if aim
assist
is indeed paramount to cheating
vis-a-vis cross-play
and you can't get rid of a whole hog
since the casuals need it
what's the solution well it's actually
very simple take it out of
competitive i've always been like this
and i've always said there shouldn't
be aim assist or controllers or whatever
in tournaments like you shouldn't mix it
either you go only controller or you go
only
pc this isn't some hot spicy
revolutionary take
but apparently it begs repeating if
controllers are
ever up against keeves and any amount of
money is on the line
aim assist should categorically be taken
out of the equation
if joe nobody me comes in to play
against
mouse aimers and i have my steroid aim
assist on and i can compete
that's that should never happen
so there's got to be some way to adjust
the degree
based on you know someone's level of
skill and and who
who on earth knows how to do that look
the reality is that if you're gonna
compete in a shooter at a high level
you gotta learn how to use a mouse and
keyboard no matter how you slice it
aim-centric esports are just
better with a clicker and a clock pad
there's a reason that they scrapped
siege's xbox pro league back in 2017.
it just isn't fun watching people click
heads with inferior hardware
that said it is never too late to level
up
look at space station gaming's very own
bosco
he won the first six invitational on
xbox
took up mouse and keyboard after his
division of pro league got cancelled
and three years later became the first
siege competitor in
history to win an invitational on both
pc
and console so as condescending as this
may sound
i say it in earnest console players
switch to pc as soon as you can and
start
practicing most of you are young enough
that you'll be nutty before you know it
and mouse users stop demonizing your
stick
thumbing brethren are there certain
annoyances
surrounding aim assist you bet your ass
there are but that isn't controller
players fault
it also doesn't change the fact that
maligned as it is
this mechanic played a vital role in
turning shooters into the
wildly popular pastime they are today
like it or not
esports owes a great deal to aim assist
so instead of berating its constituents
help them evolve guide them shepherd
them
show them some love because at the end
of the day the goal is to grow
competitive gaming for the better not
gatekeepers you know the best way to bm
in counter-strike this comes courtesy of
shout out to alex debits over at liquid
this is the former score employee this
is the alex debit special
after you clutch up for the boys in cs
get that last kill to fuse the bomb just
just like
waggle your mouse and then just hardcore
like just hard lock take your hand off
the mouse
and just freeze your freezer your pov
and then just all chat one stack my
batteries and my controller just died
that's amazing i know right it's good